okay ah welcome everybody to the 14th
annual Christmas tree lecture I I don't
know how many of you have seen any of
the others but at this time of year I
try to um say what's the coolest thing I
learned about trees during the year and
um and it seems that there's there's
always plenty of stuff uh uh new to
learn about trees um and who knows what
I'll learn next year but uh uh but uh if
I don't learn anymore well maybe this
will be the last but I I doubt it uh so
nice to see a lot of old friends and a
lot of new friends here tonight uh I got
uh I'm in a great position uh when
you're giving a talk uh it's suppos it's
always um
uh um more fun when you have something
to say and uh in fact though I'm I think
I'm suffering from from a little bit of
of too much to say tonight uh because
there's I learned so much about this
topic zdds since uh uh the beginning of
Summer that um that I can't really tell
you uh even half of it I I mean I would
need three or four lectures to uh to go
through and and and and I really believe
that U uh that if I were still active in
teaching uh I I would enjoy teaching a
one a full one quarter course just out
of the uh out of this part of of my uh
book that I that I finished the draft um
take a look at this I see if Jason can
get on here this
is you can download this right now uh
it's called a pref fasal uh you can
download this and uh I have to warn you
it's
uh 140 some 140 some pages um uh
including the index um and not only that
but uh I'm going to change it next week
so if you download it now it be it' be a
mistake to print it uh you know wait and
wait a couple of weeks um uh but what's
going to happen is that after after I
after I make the uh the revisions that I
that I recently learned about um then
then uh I'm going to combine this with
prefco 1A which is uh we'll then make a
paperback book called fasle one and and
we're expecting to publish that about
the end of January and that will that
will um
uh then then the the beginning of art of
computer programming volume four will
all be in place then uh starting with
fical 0 1 2 3 and four uh which makes
about 800 and some pages of of of of
material uh this is the missing link
that that goes between zero and the and
and two three and four that have that
have already been uh publ so anyway this
but this section alone just this the
second half of fasal one uh I I say I
could make a course out of it um uh for
uh Advanced uh uh undergrads and um and
uh and beginning grad students uh and I
don't think you know and I might still
not get through all the stuff because
there is just an awful lot of good stuff
uh that I I believe is is of of lasting
value that uh that I had no idea was
there when I began to work on this
material um now okay so how many people
were at my lecture that I gave on in in
June about bdds where I talked about at
the beginning oh about half of the
people how many people know what a bdd
is binary decision diag how many don't
know what a bdd
is oh good good uh actually the the less
you know about bdds the better in some
sense I think because it well
uh know anyway what I'm going to talk
about today the zdd as as we get into it
it it it um it's an outgrowth of of bdds
in a sense that this this thing called a
bdd was discovered first and then about
uh seven eight years later came the zdds
uh as a variation um uh uh it's it's I
might as well write his name down right
now um it was introduced by sh shinichi
manato in um
um and
uh uh and he had noticed that when he's
working on combinatorial problems um uh
he could say he could he could do a lot
better than than than a bdd by by
changing the data structure a little bit
and so zdd came along as a variation of
the bdd uh and and and the word zdd uh
it was actually he called it zero
supressed binary decision diagram and
then and then for a while this was
called a
zbd and more recently there's uh U it's
getting so important that we can't uh
bother to say so many letters all the
time we used to right so so so now we
you know zdd and there's a I don't know
300,000 Google hits for for for the the
zdd that means U um a decision diagram
there's also a lot of other flaky stuff
that you can always find on you give any
three letters to the to Google and it
and it'll it'll turn up some relation to
erotic things and so on but but um but
but this is erotic enough for me this
Computing
um the so but but um but I'm saying
maybe your knowledge of bdd might might
be hurtful to understand Zs because it's
actually even though um a lot of the
theory it it shares U great deal of the
theory with the bdds for almost every
everything that that's U that we study
uh quantitatively about bdd there's a
corresponding theorem uh about zdd um
still it's there there there's a
dramatic difference between the two in
the intuition in in the kind of things
for that they're good at U uh in with
bdds uh uh uh you really want to try to
find a way that keep the number of
variables down uh with zdds u maybe
you're better off having a lots of
variables instead of just a few
variables and and anyway so I'm going
trying to explain uh uh that that's
really a different concept uh the bdd
was invented to as a great data
structure and as the data structure of
choice for Boolean functions
representing a Boolean function inside
the a computer uh zdd is is is not not
really a data structure for Broan
function it's it's a DAT it's a data
structure for what manato called sets of
combinations um but there's so many
other names for this in in in the world
um and what I what I believe is the um
uh probably the the most common and the
most easy uh and he agrees with me now
uh is families of
sets so it's zdd is the is is I believe
the data structure of choice represent a
family of sets now what is a family of
set well it's it's a set of sets um it's
uh uh but I just call it a family of
sets because uh I may call I could have
called it a set of families or something
but we got to have I want to have two
two words uh so that there there's two
levels there well there's three levels
there's objects of a universe and then
there's sets of objects and then sets of
sets of objects or families of sets of
objects okay so when so a huge number of
combinatorial problems uh uh are based
on studying a family of sets of objects
and um uh and uh in fact uh it's it's
the the fancy the fancy name is really a
hypergraph a hypergraph is a family of
sets
um you know what a graph is a graph is a
is a a set of edges and an edge is but
it's a family of edges a graph is a
family of edges each Edge has two
elements to in it well a hyper graph is
a family of edges but each Edge might
have you know any number of elements in
it so so you just so uh so again zdd is
um the uh data structure of
choice uh uh in many cases for
representing uh a hypergraph uh inside a
computer except that the kind of things
that people do with traditionally with
hypergraphs only only is a few kind of
things that people do with families of
sets and and and many other uh
applications of families of sets are
occur in commor and they don't call them
hypergraphs because they don't use any
geometric intuition in the way that the
graph theorists do so I I like family of
said now the the question for me is what
happened if um if manato would have
invented U the zdd structure first and
then the bdd had had come along eight
eight years after that you know what
would this what would this thing be
called uh I have no idea we might have
called an HDD or something for
hypergraph but but uh but but then bdd
might have been thought of as a as a VAR
end of zdd um somehow I I hope it'll be
clear uh when I finally get into telling
you what it's all what it really is
instead of just talking about the name
uh I hope it'll be clear to you that
these are U that that it's nice to think
of it uh as if you uh you want a data
structure for a family of sets and not
to to think about it as uh you want
something that's that's that's related
to Boolean functions but then you're
modifying it for combinatorial
application um at at the end of my
lecture in and June uh David Dill um
raised a question he said Don you
haven't talked about
zdds uh did you realize that that
there's this other structure that's good
for uh uh U commentator problems and I
said and I said yeah I'm just about to
start looking at them I haven't written
that part yet of my and I'm going to
spend the summer doing that and wow what
happened during the summer I kept I I I
kept learning every week I kept I seeing
more and more things that uh
uh powerful things that about this the
CDD that I that I had no idea was there
and and I I believe it's correct to say
that most of the people um
um most of the stuff isn't really in
very much in the literature um I I there
there there are uh there are a lot of
great papers there but the but the when
I saw other people citing these papers
they just would would sort of Parry the
parot the abstract and they didn't
really seem to understand the the
brilliant ideas that were in those
papers so I so I think although the
authors of these of these paper you know
I'm not the only person that that that
saw this it's it's funny that the that
the community
using zdds has has not been the the the
the commor community that that deserves
to use it the most so far and so uh a
lot of this beautiful stuff is still way
is still in its infancy and um and in
fact um I finally decided that you know
I I I I'd better just wrap up this book
it's already already way longer than it
should be and uh and there's no way that
I'm going to get to the end of it every
week I keep finding them another thing
that's that deserves to be in there uh
so let's let it you know anyway I I I I
can't solve all the problems of the
world and I let everybody have the fun
of of of of of doing it so I'm just
going to give you a whole bunch of
examples of of the beginning of this
subject so let let's now let um let's
start so we have a family ass set and uh
uh more precisely I mean a a family of
subsets of an ordered universe so so I
have an
a universe and the universe is ordered
um and U and so the so we we have the
empty family is one thing uh we got to
start with the with with the simplest
stuff and and anybody who knows me knows
that I I like to start
small all the time I I I I I don't know
I feel I'm more in charge so the empty
family and we call this the empty
Set uh with um well I could write it in
Tech but forget it then there's the unit
family which is the the next simplest um
uh family of sets and it okay the empty
family has no sets whatsoever the unit
family has one set but the set it's
empty so it's the set consisting of the
empty set okay so we write it this way
and then I need a notation for that so
I'm going to call that
Epsilon now okay so we represent that
inside the computer the empty family
corresponds to a a note in the computer
that I that I write this way as a bottom
element um and I put a square around it
u meaning that it's a it it's a node
that doesn't have any it's not going to
point to any other node so now the the
uh unit family is going to correspond
also to one of these uh sync nodes but
this the top what but I call it with
this and and when we're when we were
doing Boolean functions uh
um uh the uh um the all zero Boolean
function correspond to this guy and the
all one Boolean function correspond to
this guy with the zdd however the
function that corresponds to this guy U
is is not the all one function but it's
the function that is true only when all
the variables are false um it's a it's a
family that has only
one um so so the BL function is is true
um okay I I I better say why is why are
Boolean functions like families of sets
uh and the answer is um we can if you
have if you have any Boolean function uh
on on this universe uh so every every
possible subset of the universe uh
corresponds to an encoding of the uh of
of some of some Boolean variables X1 X2
up to xn as to whether or not um uh you
know any set corresponds to U we set XI
to one if if if if element I is in the
set otherwise x i is zero and so um so
Broan function is true at a certain
number of of of antles X1 through xn
those are the those are called the
solutions of the Boolean function what
are the X so that f ofx is one and every
X
can be thought of as a set u if x is 0 1
and 01 this is a set consisting of two
and four say for something like that um
okay so then the set of all solutions is
a family of sets um so so so if you have
a family of sets you can you can define
a Boolean function that is equal to one
at all at at all combinations of X that
Define one of the sets of the family and
it's equal to zero in the other cases
any so so
families of sets is can be encoded as a
Boolean function uh but sometimes it's
much better to think of them as just in
terms of families of sets and elements
and things like this directly instead of
instead of thinking them Boolean wise um
now
um the more complicated family so f is
any other
family uh besides the empty family and
the unit family then
um uh uh what do we know about it well
it's it it's not empty so it has at
least one element one one one set in the
family and it's not the unit family so
there's at least some element in in this
set okay so um so we say let V be the
least
element of the
Universe um that F
supports um this is just got to have
some some some some word f supports it
meaning that it it appears in at least
one member of f there at least some set
of the family that contains V okay so so
we look at all the variables that that
occur and I said that U wasn't was an an
ordered universe and it's a finite
Universe if you if you're a
mathematician you'd say what do you do
what do you mean the real numbers
something it's got to be a well-ordered
universe then
but I see Percy in the back row I just
heard him give a marvelous lecture about
well-ordered sets and so okay but uh
anyway
um
I'm I'm willing to go some sometimes up
to accountable Infinity but but in for
computer programming it's hard to get
beyond that now um okay so there is some
smallest smallest element of the
universe that appears in one of the sets
if we're not one of these two family and
and so um and and so I um I can Define
two subfamilies now F0 is the set of all
sets the family of all sets uh that are
in the family F and V is not a member of
Alpha and F1 is is the set of all
uh Alpha uh is the set of all set the
family of all sets so that Alpha
together with v is is in the family and
and V is not in the
set okay so um in other words just knock
out V from all the ones that's in this
gives us two subfamilies either either
they contain v or they don't contain v
and then um uh inside the computer f is
represented as a circular node uh which
is sort of I branch on V and then I I I
a a dotted line to F0 and a solid line
to F1 and here I give the
representations of F0 and F1 uh but now
V isn't in there anymore so it's going
so so I can continue this definition
recursively until eventually I get a
representation of of the whole family of
sets okay well I'll give an
example
um uh so that you're all with
me um
in fact uh I I could show you an example
if I were using PowerPoint you know but
uh I've been sitting through so many
PowerPoint lectures where the the guy
turns
the clicks too fast for me and so I'm
I'm going to draw out a solution so that
you can see what do I'm going to
consider I mean instead of just just
flashing the answer to you I'm going to
actually I'm actually write it out here
and so let's let's suppose that f is the
is a very simple family it's going to be
the Two element
subsets
um of um of the universe 1 2
okay and so this is um in other words
well it it could be called S Sub 2 of 1
3 and so um so how how do I represent F
well what's the smallest element of the
universe that that's supported by this
you you you see F has has three sets in
it 1 2 1 3 and 2 three that's the family
we're talking about what about one one 2
two and 3 three one one no that's
multisets we're talking about two
element subsets so so uh um a set is a
set doesn't have repeated elements um uh
you can represent mully sets also by by
uh by a sequence of zdds um and
and Manata does this by for example
having a zdd for all the things that
appear uh all the sets that occur an odd
number of times and then another one for
all all that occur an odd multiple of
two number of times and things like that
and and you can you can play games like
that but that's that's that's one of the
things that I won't talk about anymore
today uh but that's okay keep asking
questions when you when they when they
occur to you that's the way I this is
interactive okay so so we start out
um uh there's two uh so so the smallest
uh variable the smallest element that's
that's supported is one and there and
there are the sets that contain one and
the sets that don't contain one so the
the ones that um
um uh that don't contain one are uh S2
of two and three the Two element sets of
two and
three uh the ones that do contain one
after you throw one out are what they're
the S1 of two three they're the things
that contain one more element of of two
and three okay and so um um I can you
know so I can expand this out with a
recursive idea here I'll put a two and
then I'm going to have s um on this side
it's going to be S2 of three which which
turns out to be nothing uh null so so
this will go to the empty family uh but
if it if it doesn't contain one but it
does contain two then it's got uh then
then we come to S1 of three which is
going to be
three um and uh you know if three
doesn't have uh if if if three isn't
isn't in there then we lose but if three
is there uh then we
win um uh because uh if it if it doesn't
contain one does contain two does
contain three uh what's left is the
empty family which is this guy here I'm
sorry the unit family
Epsilon um now on on the right hand
Branch I'm going uh uh I'm going to S1
of two and three so it means I want one
element out of either two or three but
not both so if I don't have two well
let's let's suppose I do have
two then I better not have
three okay
uh so what what's what's the case there
it would be it would be s0 of three and
that's the unit family so so this go
Branch will go right down to
here um if it contains one and two it
comes here but we don't mention three we
bypass three really it that means three
can't appear in this in this Branch it's
not supported on this branch on the
other hand on the if if you look at it
um you coming coming this wait wait a
minute I I I I did I do did I do this
wrong let's see
S3 is yeah um no yeah that's yeah I
think I this is fine so
um um but if I have one um uh but I
don't have two then I've got to have
three all right but now notice I came to
the same node and that's something I for
got to tell you that is we always uh
make sure that no node appears twice in
our data structure and this is a huge
importance uh uh so although I'm I'm
saying I'm giving a Christmas tree
lecture and it looks like I'm I'm giving
you a tree here because I have a root
and I've got these branches um this
isn't a true tree because uh overlapping
subt trees are combined into one this is
a directed a cyclic graph not a not a
true
uh not strictly a tree but I'll bring
trees in later don't worry uh um so
um in inside the computer then uh these
what I drew as circles and and squares
are are nose a few a few cells of memory
filled with with with with three things
um and um well I I I'll give it more
detail in a second but um
uh uh well in fact yeah why don't I do
that let let me let me do one more
example and I'll do this one I'll do
this one real quick and you stop me if I
if I make a mistake uh but here I'm
going to have a family that contains two
sets um one two and
four question yeah um on the first piece
of paper that we're working with yeah
first piece of paper at the bottom you
talk on the F1 is equal to the union
of Alpha and V that's this one here F1
okay this is this is the family of all
Alpha such that Alpha Union V is in F so
Alpha is a set
of of elements and if I throw V in it I
I could I could have put a v in I could
have put braces around the V yeah this
is uh this is this is a simplification
that's often used by people who are
given lectures uh
also also by people who are giving who
are writing textbooks and doing doing
research in with sets uh uh uh we we we
uh allow ourselves to uh to consider a
what uh a one element Set uh but
actually you know uh you're a true
computer scientist because afraid I
dropped one level no no no this is
you're a true computer scient because a
when you're programming you got to know
the difference um okay but uh you know
so so so so you're correct in in in in
in now I'm very glad are on record now
saying that I'm a true computer
SCI is your boss sitting in the same row
I'm going to
show I really meant it yeah now okay so
here's another uh you another simple
example let's let's let's do this
quickly what's the smallest element
supported here one right um so now if I
if I don't have a one then what's going
to happen I I I'm looking at the uh yeah
you want maybe you want my my definition
up here but uh okay so um so okay so so
if I don't have a one what's what's left
it it it it's a family of one set four
and so um that's easy that's that goes
like
this okay um uh now the other one
um um if it does have a one then we have
to
have similar thing but with two instead
right so it just goes like that
now let me throw another family into the
into the mix here too uh because uh G is
another family and G is a family
containing the empty set first and and
one two and
now uh the reason I'm doing two two
families ass sets instead of just one is
because really uh when we're working in
in the computer we don't have just one
zdd for one family we got lots of
families that we're that we're working
with uh in in a problem and so we really
have a not just a zdd but a zdd base a
whole you know
uh and and and we share the data
structures among everything in the in
the zdd base so so this is is this is
sort of f uh corresponds to to this node
but G will correspond to another node
what's the smallest uh uh thing uh
what's the smallest element uh in this
universe for G well that's uh uh that's
also one is is the smallest guy that
appears so if I if I now uh say one does
not appear uh what is the left branch of
of
um um in that case for
G anybody don't don't worry about Mak
what the Epsilon absolutely so so that
goes down here but if if it does contain
one then it's it's a family that
contains either two or
four all right so um it's going to go
then we're going to check on Two And and
if if if uh two is in there
then good but if two isn't in there it's
going to be
for okay so anyway this is a zdd base
for for both f and g and let's suppose
that I that that that I put these in
memory so so I can has cell zero for for
for the bottom syn sell one for the top
sink I might put this in location two uh
the order of these other locations isn't
really important um um but I might as
well uh match my notes so call this
location five this location six here so
now inside uh inside a
machine
uh we
could yeah when you said that there
there was a requirement that no node
appears twice that's just for one of the
functions or so I'm seeing the two being
repeated the and you're seeing you're
seeing a two being repeated no two both
yeah right but once it but in one case
it has
yeah the the the the dotted branch is uh
is going over here and in the other case
the dotted branch is going over here so
it's not the same node it uh and and
that'll be clear in a minute that if if
you look at this picture here um let's
so this picture corresponds to that that
zdd base uh so so each node I'm saying
has three parts a V part a low pointer
and a high pointer
and uh and uh for these syn nodes I'm
I'm calling the V part Infinity
um and so so and then I'm just saying
the low low and high point to themselves
but uh the other cases so so for example
in location two here the V part is four
uh the left Branch goes the low Branch
goes here the high Branch goes to one uh
uh in location three I have another I
have this guy uh the the low Branch goes
to zero the high Branch goes to one in
in location four the low Branch goes to
two and the high Branch goes to one all
right so
the so this is the way it looks inside
the inside the computer there's also a
hash table to keep track that that so
that uh if somebody later wants to make
a node that we we want to check that
that we've already got it or not so
there's this law here no two nodes have
the same triple V low and high
uh furthermore there's no node that has
high equals zero this is an important
point this is why manato called them Z
zero suppressed bdds in the first place
you never have high equal zero except
node zero itself here um um and um you
see you see why because if you if if if
you're going on the high Branch you
you're talking about um uh uh going to
some non-empty family ass
sets you would go to the you wouldn't
have a high Branch at all if you weren't
supported uh there has to be some you
were supported so you have to be you
know you were in some set so so so
you'll never go to
a you never go to zero in this in this
Branch okay now the other the other
condition here is that this ordering is
important so that when you do go to the
low Branch you go to a a larger V field
than you had
yourself and to high Branch the same way
so so the B fields are always increasing
as you you know as as you as you follow
down this this structure so so this is
this is the whole idea of a zdd now
um and not not uh hard to implement but
not trivial either because of this uh of
this hash table which goes on behind the
scenes and then we we uh want to
uh think no uh turn out that it turns
out that we're going to want to uh uh
find space for new nodes and then other
nodes are going to be are going to die
and we and we want to recycle them and
so garbage collection has to go on
behind the scenes and all that uh isn't
really as simple as I'm going to but I'm
going to I'm going to forget about it
for the rest of this talk uh uh you read
my book and talks about other things
about what what goes on to make it but
this is the whole the whole basis of of
the of the of the the data structure
now one more thing I you might as well
notice here and that is that uh uses the
elements 1 2 and four it would have been
just it wouldn't have been any bigger if
I had used the elements uh 1 million 2
million and 4 million uh uh but if I was
talking about a Boolean function um I
would have had to have have to have
extra things saying that all of these
all of these variables that that haven't
been mentioned um uh have to have to
evaluate to Zero have have to be not
presentent so uh the
uh so if I were representing this as a
Boolean function of of the variables 1 2
3 and four uh I would have to worry
about
three um say saying that X3 has to be
zero and so I have to a lot of I would
have to come and test X3 in in several
places so um this is why manato found
that he was he's working on a lot of
comor problems and he's looking at
booing functions that he got with those
comori problems and and a lot of those
uh booing functions had the property
that uh uh there were there were very
there were there were high branches that
were always zero and he he just wanted
to eliminate um that's that's where it
started but but but uh my point is that
really if we if we just Inuit the whole
idea of family of sets and and keep Ming
functions as something that we'll think
about tomorrow instead of today then uh
this is a natural data structure just in
the family of sets world and that's and
the family of sets World um has lots of
different users than the than the
Boolean function World okay well now I
this is the Christmas tree lecture and I
so so I want to bring in trees before I
before I get into other kind of and so
let me let me show you
one um thing about trees here um
uh one of our previous lectures we've
talked about Professor nested
parentheses um as represent microphone
oh thank you Jason
well all right where did you lose me
so welcome to another
Christmas um all right m parentheses are
are one of the the important ways to to
describe tree structure inside a
computer and I'm not going to dwell on
that but but uh here here here are the
five ways to uh to take three left
parentheses and three right parentheses
and have them properly nested now now
let me U uh uh imagine that these are
that these are words and we're going to
go more into words later on so I'm going
to call this L1 L2 2 L3 R 4 R5 R6 for
the first one meaning that the first the
first uh character is is a left
parenthesis and so on the fourth
character is a right parenthesis and so
on so so here we are L1 L2 R3 L4 R5
R6 L1 L2 R3 R4 L5 R six
uh you get the idea but I'm still going
to persist here L3 L4 R 5 R6 and L1 R2
L3 R4 L5 R6 now this is a family of sets
believe it or not because I could put
braces around all these things and the
universe is the is a set of uh well okay
sorry um when did L2 become
R2 something when did
l in which line do you want the second
line uh R2 yeah the the third and fourth
lines don't
really uh work
together this line right R4 R4 and and
L2 on fourth line R4 that should be L2
and
R number there's a there's a number
there's there's the third letter is an L
fourth letter is an L the fifth and
sixth are are R so yeah this is a this
is not the standard way to to represent
parentheses I'm not subscripting them
according to their rank or anything just
according to the position in the string
and and so uh imagine I have a universe
of of 12 letters L1 R1 L2 R2 up to L6 R6
and this is these are five uh families
of from that from that universe and I
can
I can
um um write down the zdd for it which
turns out to be really nice and simple
uh and I I have it here in my cheat
sheet if I can find it but but other
otherwise I'll just uh wing
it what I think it's it's on the bottom
half of your oh hey no it's not no no if
you pull the pad down oh okay
so pull the pad down
what and now you're holding it this guy
yeah but this is here here I did only
the L's and or and only the RS but oh
okay that's but I want to do both both
uh
both okay so U because it's more it
turned out that when I gave when I did
this um I thought it I didn't think of
combining the L's and rs but it's better
to combine the L's and rs so so okay so
here we go no that's not what I did
though okay
well
maybe aha it's the back
sheet okay so I start with
L1 and um if I don't have an L1 I'm dead
um they all they all have an L1 uh so I
I I could write dot dot dot and go to
the null uh to the empty syn but uh
that's going to mess up the diagram
there's going to be lots and lots of dot
dot dot the empty syn so I'm just going
um not going to write any of those any
of those guys uh if if it's dot dot dot
to the empty I'm not going to write it
then L2 is is a branch Point here and um
um uh and and if I don't have an L2 I
got to have an
R2 um if but then if I have the R2 then
it's got to be
L3 um and and either L4 or R4 I'll just
draw the whole darn thing out here and
then L5
um now what this other branch is coming
down here if I have L1 and L2 then L3 is
a possibility or if not R3
here and that's a solid line
there this is sloppy but
that's that's the point that you have to
supply some of your own intelligence so
that makes you think about this right so
here so the idea is that the
um that it's a it's a it's a
pretty pretty nice and tidy uh
CDD and um as I said if there's only one
branch coming out of these guys that
means that uh uh uh you're supposed to
just die and uh and go down to the uh to
the null sink now um
uh 14 nodes Al together there's a null
sync sitting out here getting a whole
bunch of stuff 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
12 13 14 uh and it's representing a
family of size five well that's not a
great win we could we could we just
store the family of size five um there
but if I If instead I this is the case n
equals 3 I have three uh three
parentheses but um uh if you go to n Nal
24 for example uh then um
um uh the corresponding thing uh it it
it would look something like this it
would start out actually the same way um
and it would have 602 nodes
total and uh uh the total number of
solutions uh the total number of trees
that it encodes is uh you know a
trillion and some so this a nice compact
way to represent trees
and you're representing all these trees
you don't have to generate them all you
can you know you've got uh you you can
ask questions uh like uh uh now we can
we can look at at at the families that
contain L6 or something like that uh
very easily so so so small small space
inside the computer we can represent
large commor sets of interest and then
we can represent other large common
sense of interest and then operate on on
them together and and solve and solve
other problems about them uh efficiently
uh for example random generation uh if
you have any uh um any family of sets
represented as a zdd you can uh uh you
can you can uh quickly in terms of the
size of the zdd uh get a random family
uh a random set of the family okay now
let's see how are we doing on time okay
so now now I got to talk about lots and
lots of applications instead of talking
about the the nuts and bolts um and
we'll see see some of the things we can
do so um operations on the families is
is the next thing um
and and um depending on what part of
comics you look at you find lots of of
uses for families of sets and people in
different branches of comat toic have
different operations that that they're
uh uh that they're
uh that are that are key for them but
the the very the very natural the very
simplest ones are just take the union of
two families so f and g are families of
sets and and the union of two families
is the family of all sets Alpha so that
Alpha is in F or Alpha is in
G great F of intersect G is the set of
all uh the family of all sets that are
in in both f and
g uh F uh set minus of G is the set of a
family of all sets that are in F but not
in G and U so
on um I I might as well go through this
because
U uh it's not going to take that long so
this is the
uh
um f symmetric difference between f and
g is f minus G or G minus
F now it suppose f is uh is a family of
sets represented as a zdd with F0 and F1
here and G is a family that is has W uh
and F and g0 and G1 uh as its
representation uh
the uh the algorithm for computing all
four of these operations is very simple
and um so that um
uh I'll
um I I I'll show you for for for all
four cases we have F union g f intersect
g f minus g f symmetric difference with
G and uh there's three cases if V equals
w
um then um uh in other words the both of
them have the
smallest element of support then what do
we get for the union well if it if it if
it doesn't contain v uh we want this we
want the union of all of all things that
were in F or in G so um if it doesn't
contain v then it's got to be uh it's
going to be here
F0 Union g0 the ones that that weren't
in in there and it's easy to see really
that this is also F1 Union
G1 so recursively uh we just uh U go
down to to the descendants of of f and g
and continue the same process eventually
we get down to a sink or we get to a a a
sub problem we've seen before and we and
we don't have to and we keep a a AO cach
so that we don't have have to do the
same operation uh that we've already
that we' already already done uh once we
know that uh once we've computed a union
uh uh we remember it so we don't have to
uh compute it again uh this one um same
thing uh if it's not
in we do F0 intersect g0 FS1 intersect
G1 in fact it's going to be the same for
the difference and the and um F0
difference g0 FS1 difference
G1 and and
um um F0 plus g0 FS1 plus G1 the the
interesting thing occurs if if V is is
is different from w v is less than W for
example um then um
uh uh that means that that uh V occurs
in the family F but it doesn't occur in
the family G so in the case of Union U
the algorithm is that we take F0 Union G
here and here we just Branch to F1 which
we already
knew um in the case of
intersection well what we actually do is
um the V is not going to occur in the
intersection and so so we just give the
we just take F intersected with g0 and
and V doesn't even appear in the in in
the result and uh similarly for this one
it's F minus g0 and and in the and in
the last one uh it uh it turns out that
it's w not v no V sorry it's
v ah I I I no I I um I did this wrong
there's V here going to F1 and on this
side it's F0 mod with G well anyway you
can work out these these details and um
um uh I don't have time to um to dwell
on this just to point out that it's easy
recursive process once you've
got once you located the smallest
element that's supported then it's then
you can recursively Define these
operations on the remaining sets and the
the other there's a third case v is
greater than W and it's not symmetrical
uh to the case v less than less than W
because uh U these rules are notm
between left and right we have a a rule
about suppressing zero off of the high
Branch but we don't have a rule about
suppressing zero off the off the low
bran yeah um if V is equal to W then F +
G should not have V right f plus
G uh yeah yeah there will be there will
be uh uh take for example um uh f is
equal to 1 2 and G is equal to 13 um now
um uh F0
is uh um the things that are in that are
in F but not in G or in G but not are in
F is the same as the Union in this case
I let let's take suppose I had this one
then f+ G is going to be 1 2 1
3 it's the set it's it's the difference
the these are not elements of the sets
they're they're they're elements of the
family they're sets of the family yeah
it's uh in fact uh but I'm glad you
asked that because that's that leads to
my next definition so there are other
operations on families that
we um well
no I'll get to it in a minute but uh but
um um the these are operations at the
top level uh we're taking the union of
two families but we're not taking the
union of the elements of the sets in the
families but that's another important
operation on families which we're going
to get to in a minute uh be yeah um so
if we intersect um two sets that both
have support for an element how do we
know the intersection of support for the
element it doesn't if if we intersect
two sets that both have support for an
element yeah then what um the
intersection does not necessarily have
support for the elements so why can we
have a note this is true it it um yeah
actually um uh if this turns out to be
if this turns out to be the empty set
then then we actually leave leave the uh
yeah I I I should have mentioned that I
really don't come come to this but a
afterwards when I get to to checking
whether this Noe actually appears I I um
okay if if I ever try to create a node
that looks like V uh empty uh Alpha then
I just convert that to
Alpha yeah you you um so that's right
that my my uh my subverting create a
node uh froze this case
out did I answer your question what so
so so it it so although I this is the
recursion that that I do afterwards if
this guy turns out to be empty then then
then we don't put this in this V in the
data structure after all because because
of course this whole thing might be um
might be
empty
um if um all right
yeah now but but uh uh I got to get to
the application because these are the
amazing things and I and I'll have to
just zoom through these
so one of the um
application um what one is uh uh exact
cover
problem so one of the one of the one of
the
combinatorial um applications that uh
for which zds are are great is uh
something like this suppose I want
to well maybe I'll I'll get it out of my
notes here this is uh
um yeah
um so okay so for example suppose you
want to cover a chessboard with with 32
dominoes um now um and how many ways are
there to do this well uh uh it turns out
there's 13 million um ways to do it uh
but this is just an example of many
other kind of exact covering problems
and um we can describe that as as a big
Matrix of zeros and ones where each row
of the Matrix is one way to place a
domino on the chessboard so I could put
a domino on the first two squares or I
could put a domino vertically on the
first square and the you know and then
the the square in the next row this is
this is 64 imagine 64 columns here and
then I have 112 rows for the different
places that you can put a domino on a
chess on a chessboard um and what we're
trying to do is is find 32 of these rows
uh that exactly cover everything so if
we add up those 32 rows we get one one
one one one one one one one that's an
exact cover problem now
um uh we we can consider this a family
of sets where where the the winning sets
are the way to choose the sets of 32
rows that that uh solve this
problem the sets of sets of domino
positions that cover the chest boort uh
well it turns out that the the the the
zdd has 2,300 nodes uh for that problem
uh but you know there are 112 uh places
to put the the Domino um uh but but the
zdd has it and and and it's easy Once
you have zdd it's easy to count um the
number of solutions now uh here here's a
more interesting more exotic kind of a
covering problem in this case I'm
covering the chess board not only with
dominoes but with monomino or trino okay
so in other words I I can have I can
have uh one cell or uh like here or
three cells and the trinos can be either
uh this l-shape or or or a long Domino
um so um now uh how many ways are there
to do this okay 92 you know this is this
long big number here 92 uh uh sex CH I
don't know what it is and uh it it takes
almost no time to figure that out uh uh
you have 468 variables now there's 468
ways to place one of these ominos uh
somewhere on the chessboard and and that
gives you a um uh U Zach cover problem
with 468 rows um and uh the zdd turns
out to have 512,000 nodes to it um and
it doesn't take very long it's well
the the calculation here I said take 75
megga Ms I I I I measure all the all the
running times in my book by memory
accesses because this is something that
stays the same even though computers
keep changing according to M's law so 70
5 million times that I loaded or stored
from memory uh and and I calculated the
number of ways to do this covering okay
now now that that so that's one kind of
applic one cool of zdd
um uh we can go further in fact
um yeah in the 75 megga are you
including the algorithm that you use to
compute the
zdd uh this was this was uh I I started
with the um the
468 rows or whatever it was I started
with the uh with the given zeros and
ones but that's just trivial to to
create that um so so so that's not going
to be a million more so so so what I
what I'm counting is the the it
everything that's involved with uh with
with building the data structure garbage
collection and and uh caching and
everything that that I'm doing in order
to make sure that I that I don't have
any repeated nodes and and I by the way
my my program for this is on is on the
web uh it's called bdd 15
um you can get it from my downloadable
programs page
um and and it shows you the way I did
the uh uh it's it's instrumented so so
that it shows you how I counted these uh
these
men okay now
um
you while I'm while I'm into dominoes
let's consider uh some of the some of
the ways of placing dominoes uh uh work
out with three colors you can imagine
red dominoes white dominoes and blue
dominoes and you give yourself a rule
that you're not going to allow any two
of them to uh to touch maybe at the
corners but not but but you can't have a
a red one a red that has a whole Edge in
common with another red one and so on
okay so now here's here's an exercise
where
um uh and uh want to use we want to use
zdds for this um uh how many this is
exercise 216 believe it or not um uh how
many ways can I cover a chessboard with
red white blue dominoes with no two
dominoes of the same color next to each
other and
um the
answer um let's see exercise 216 the
answer to exercise 216
is
um oh well let's see we get it
here
um let me see I I I got the
numbers yeah the number of RS was 13
billion
um uh it gives
every every coloring six times because
red white and blue uh would occur in
different anyway there are 13 billion
ways to do it uh and the Z and and the
running time was uh uh 1.2 Gams uh so
1.2 billion Ms so so in other words
uh uh less than one/ tenth of the of the
number of solution you know for every
solution that that occurs you you you
spent one/ tenth of a memory access in
order to in order to determine it and
and and uh uh represented now the um the
second part of this exercise says how
many um sorry how many of the of the
Domino coverings these 13 million Domino
coverings how many of them are three
colable this is a different problem
because sometimes uh there's many
there's many ways to take a domino
covering and color it with red red white
and blue um but other ones there's no
way whatsoever so how many of them are
are three colorable well that turned out
with again with zdds um and another 1.3
gamm you could you could uh determine
that answer and the and it was
um uh see what exercise are we talking
so so so I have this UNC coloring
function which is which is easy to do
recursively and the answer is 3 million
in some um so these are problems that I
have no idea could could be by any other
method uh could could be done anywhere
nearly uh so efficiently and I've been
playing with com other kind of
combinatorial algorithms for a long time
now all right so that's that's
application one application two we're
running short of time so I got to uh uh
dictionaries
um there there's lots and lots of great
ways to store collections of words um
that that are already well known in
computer science but um uh zdds can also
do some things that these other these
other things don't
so here's an
example um suppose I'm doing the five
letter words of English uh now I I've
got uh many many examples in in in my
book are based on the set of all felter
words in the English language and it
turns out there are exactly
5,757 such words uh according to my my
definition I I I I decided in 1995 to
Define exactly what it means to be a
five letter word of English
that was that was before I knew the word
Chads and and a few other words that
have come up later like U like blogs but
um um uh anyway these are my words and
uh so uh here I do it something like I
did with the L's and rs for the
parenthesis I I I have uh uh 130
elements of My Universe A1 through Z1 uh
A2 through Z2 and so on A5 through Z5
and the word funny would would would be
represented as a set fub1 U2 N3 N4 y5
okay so the family of sets oh family
containing F 57 57 sets um and I and uh
and I'm going to tell you minute why I
write this in the notation with an f and
a
square square Union sign instead of uh
instead of another symbol there so this
is f joined with U2 joined with N3
joined with N4 it's a join operation
joining elements together into a set uh
and here's words and so on and and this
whole this whole zdd for all of the F
all of the words of five letter words of
English starts out with A1 uh and then
comes the you know the the the things
that start with A1 uh the next
possibility is to check uh uh if the
second letter is an a A2 and if if so
then the word is
ARG a r g h okay if not then then we
look for a b too okay if if you don't
have an A then you have to have a b oh
you know then you might have a b and if
you have a b then it could be an A and
it could you have you know ba a b baby I
don't know B there must be a word
studying with bab um uh and so on
uh at the bottom of the tree it's it's
kind of interesting uh um you have um
one branch comes from
Rea and then it can be either relax or
relay uh so so so um on the other hand
most other words that end with an x uh
there's only it has to be an X or
nothing so um at the bottom of the tree
we have one one uh Z5 node one y5 node
two uh X5 nodes three W5 nodes and so on
but that but you can imagine this this
big tree containing uh defining all the
57 all all the five letter words of
English now um it's similar to what we
had called a tri memory um uh but that's
a tree instead of instead of a dag uh
um Tri memory
TR
um uh but but now if we use the zdd
operations we can do more things and let
me let me give you a couple of quick um
examples of that um so uh
uh question one all
words all words of the form t blank or
uh or t something U something
H what what are the five letter words
that that have this
form
what I I I can't
hear tough okay that's a tough question
okay touch is that it what touch
touch truth
touch truth okay touch and Truth yeah
okay in fact that's
itk
what
T I'm sorry
no no
um what I do is I uh so f is my pattern
if I there's a query that I can make and
so I so I give the pattern p and p is is
a family uh containing one uh one set
and I call it T1 joined with u3 joined
with
H5 um okay and then I compute um uh
uh uh an operation on this zdd and it
will and it will very quickly give me
give me the answer but let me show you
the operations that we that that that
that I'm doing uh because this answers
the question I promised I would get to
that you asked before so if I have
there's more operations on
family uh F Square cup of G is the set
of is the family of all Alpha Union beta
such that Alpha is in F and beta is in
G
uh there's f um and this is called the
join and then there's the meat of two
families uh and that's a square cap and
this is this the set the family of all
intersections uh where we take one
element of one set from F and one set
from um uh from G all right so this is
what you were asking about before U and
it's different from the union of the two
families it's the The Joint of the two
family uh and there's also f um uh
exclusive or G which is what you had in
mind when you were asking me asking this
question it's it's the uh family of all
symmetric differences the the same way
so this is the Delta of of two families
uh there's also um uh something that I
thought of two or three weeks ago that's
uh that um
uh I don't even have time to hardly
mention it in my book I don't have I I I
know what the notation is to use for it
anyway but it's the set of all
unions um family of all unions the that
Alpha is in F beta is in G and Alpha
is is disjoint from beta the set of all
disjoint so I call this the disjoint
instead instead of the join um and this
turns out to be to be important in a lot
of comor application and it's even
easier to compute than the other one but
the the anyway these are just like we
had for the union intersection so on
there's a simple recursive definition
that that applies to zdds that computes
the joint of of of two um families the
the meat of two families Etc um and the
dis joint and sometime and and I believe
that for some of the applications that I
for which I use join if I I could have
just as well used this joint I would
have run faster but I haven't had I
don't don't have time to uh to check
this out yet there's so many things
still waiting to be done um now there's
another one that the quotient f f over G
um and
um um this is the set this is the family
of all sets uh Alpha that um have the
property that if if um Alpha Union beta
is in F and Alpha intersect beta is
empty sorry this is equals empty here
excuse me I I meant that the disjoint
not not not that they intersect so so
the disjoint was that one but this one
says that I I take a disjoint Union and
this is for all not just for for some
for all beta in G so so it says that for
example if um um if
well if G has only one if there's only
one beta alog together then it's just
saying uh uh uh uh look for all words
that that include beta look look for all
elements of F that um um uh that if we
added beta to it uh uh I'm sorry look
for all all Alphas so that if we added
added beta to them we would get it so so
so this is just like um uh something
like like the one branch uh
uh if if if G was just a family
containing the single element uh the
single element v um and and uh there's F
Modi um which is f minus G joined with f
over G uh well not time to to dwell on
on U the meaning of all these things but
I but I I just want to mention the query
that we make in order to solve this
question all words of tough touch and
Truth here we specify a pattern uh and
this would work for any pattern of
course um and then we compute F divided
by the pattern um uh and then we join
that to to to the pattern in this
particular case f ided p would be uh uh
the family that contains O2 C4 O2 G4 and
R2 T4 because this would make then we
join that to p and we and we get touch
tough and truth that that this is the
idea of of taking the quotient of
something so so you know find all words
that that that um that contain
everything in the in in the denominator
um okay now uh second query uh in in
what felter
words in what felter
words um can we
change a b to an O and still have and
get another
word
um now it's a little hard to to do this
because B is a consonant no is a vowel
so so but but there are um there are uh
a bunch of these
and uh
um in my in this notation with these
operations on families um uh I can for
example say F divided by
B1 joined with o1 no B1 Union
um um and and then I I join that with B1
this would be a word um
uh other words I look for all five
letter words that have either a be that
that have that work with with B1 and o1
both um and one of the
answer is um
busts okay busts OU okay there's also
um
basis basis goes to Oasis okay so then
you know then um uh I can do it with
with with other positions it turns out
in second position there there there are
none but if I but if I look at um the
third one here and I join that with B3
it turns out there's only one word and
it's
Bobby change to booby okay and um and
and and with and in the fourth position
um uh there there are there are three
answers and uh
um I will give you just uh one of
them uh well no I'll let you find the
others for yourself but how about
herbs okay so so you get the idea and
and so
um so with these operations that we have
on famili assets uh there's a need for a
notation for them uh I I I found no you
know I find people using these these
operations but I don't have anywhere
standard notations so I'm I'm trying to
uh promote the the notations that I that
that I came up with is that that look
fairly good uh and I've been working
with them for a while and so I call this
family algebra and so so we have an
algebra you know you have Boolean
algebra well there's also family algebra
so so family algebra has operations not
only of Union intersection has join meet
and uh and there's more um
okay um I uh Val what family value
Family Value okay this is great now
um uh and I I could I don't have time to
give you my other examples but uh but
here's like take this one F uh meet F uh
minus
F this would be f meet f is all of the
um
uh every uh it's a family of all things
that
uh that can be all all fragments of a
word all all partial words that that are
the intersection of two of two different
words uh except uh take the word with
itself
um every word uh inter Ed with itself is
is just a felter thing but but if I
throw out those then I'm getting all the
subwords that all the intersection of of
of two distinct words okay like r l
a um is one of the examples we had
before which re relay and relax would
would and and so on um now
um all intersections of two distinct
word uh and well I have lots of lots of
other examples in my book but I don't
have time to uh do it and and and some
of these calculations uh I I I believe I
can do much faster with zdds than with
the with with the ordinary ways of
representing dictionaries in the
computer
what
palindromes now called paland Drome
palr you know this one right so um
yeah but yes you
can yeah you can you can yeah okay yeah
you can you can find P you can find
Padres with uh with u with zdd and and
and other stuff too but but
but not not the fast I mean there there
are faster ways to to get to get you
know not all commor problems go go best
with ZD um uh so so let's not go overbo
but but uh so a lot of times the more
constrained it is the um uh the more
some of these more classical and simpler
methods uh um well in well-known methods
uh would go okay now uh where am I here
though I got okay so I'll never get
to
um uh okay so
well there's just so many so many things
let me let me see so um since we're yeah
I've never run so far overtime before
and you guys are very nice to stay this
long but uh so so so let me let me
explain to you what
I what I would love to to go on in more
detail and then you can download the
thing and see why I wanted to make a a
course in it so still more operations on
families we have the closure on and
these are things that people who who who
you know there's so many people working
with families of sets in different parts
of commor so we talk about the closure
the set of all intersections that you
can get um yeah anything that you can
get by any number of intersections not
just two but three intersections of
things like this um we we can ask for
the maximal uh elements of a family
those that aren't contained in any
other in other set of the family we as
for the minimal elements of the family
we uh the cross elements uh that's too
hard to explain the nons subsets the the
elements of F that are not contained in
any in any uh elements
of of G the the members of F that are
not contained in any me the the members
of I I I use this this Arrow here saying
I go away from F in the subset category
and go towards G and and going away from
f um uh uh for supersets is an arrow in
this direction and and and U by the way
there's there's also an arrow going this
way which are the subsets U the ones
that that elements of F that are subsets
of um of some element of G um so so so
you got to have notations for these
operations and all of these operations
again have nice recursive definitions on
the zdd structure and and uh don't take
much time
um APL keyboard yeah this is what what I
had well I I can use two letters but
yeah okay but but in in my um uh I I I
can't imagine what would have happened
if uh if if this had come along uh at
the time APL was designed okay uh
now uh so this gives us graph Theory um
and hypergraph Theory um so uh a graph
is a family of sets each set has has two
elements in it um a hypergraph is the
same kind of thing so the independent
sets of a graph are the power set not
contain it okay this this funny notation
like I use the vir p for for this but
but this this is the this is the family
of all
sets so so take the family of all sets
but that are not contained in any in any
element in any edge of of the of the
graph that's by definition an
independent set and and uh this has a
very simple zdd um it goes like one dot
dot dot two dot dot dot three and so on
and and uh so anyway we can we can find
all independent sets we can find the
maximal independent sets by taking the
maximum elements of that guy we can find
all the dominating sets um and uh uh
there's it fairly simple calculation
find the dominating sets of a graph the
minimal dominating
sets and uh so um
uh give you the flavor of that to
consider U the the chess board where I
have um uh queens and and consider the
graph where two cells of the chess boort
are adjacent if um if they're in the
same Row the same column or same
diagonal so now um the the famous eight
Queens problem is to find a maximum
independent set of of of of queens that
would be eight Queens like there um the
um but there's also uh
uh this is also a maximal independent
set these Queens don't attack each other
but if we place any sixth Queen here uh
it would it uh it would um it would be
in line with one of these five and so
this is called a kernel of a graph uh
it's a maximal independent set not just
an independent set and and the smallest
kernels are are are important in in many
common toal problems so so this is an
example of the smallest Kel um then uh
you have clicks here there's a maximum
click uh these are both maximal clicks
this is a maximum Click Of Queens this
one these are dominating sets um a
dominating set is is where uh
all everything that that doesn't contain
a queen on it um is attacked by some
Queen um and and um uh
this is the only case where you can
leave out the entire middle of the board
and but it's not an independent um you
know these aren't independent but they
dominate the whole board so and here's
another dominating set this is this is
this is a problem that uh not not too
well known uh Place 11 Queens in such a
way that um uh that if you take any one
of the 11 uh you leave you leave
somebody uncovered uh one of the you
know all of these cells that don't have
a queen in are covered here um U but if
I left out any one of these 11 Queens uh
uh it wouldn't it wouldn't be dominating
the whole board and you can't do that
with 12 but you can put 11 Queens this
way okay so anyway these are these are
problems that are that are very nice to
solell with zdds um and for
um all graphs and hypergraphs um uh and
in many cases I I think it's better than
backtracking better than the other
solutions that I that I used to
know okay now um so well I got these
graph problems uh then there's there's
path
problems uh and
um uh so to my to my surprise uh uh I
I take I can take problems like this
that
um uh say find all the paths from a
corner to corner of a of a square that
don't intersect them themselves that
don't intersect themselves um if we do
it on a larger grid that has 8 by8 so
this would be the number of ways to move
a rook uh from upper left corner of a
chess board to the lower right corner um
without ever going into the same cell
twice uh there's 789 billion wavs to do
it and the zdd um has some 35 34,000
nodes uh uh where the uh this is a zdz
for the 3X3 case um and uh
so um you can solve problems like about
p uh and and here's and and when I
showed this to Randy Bryant who's the
guy who invented bdds uh he said okay
Don uh uh how's this for a problem for
you uh suppose suppose I wanted to take
a driving to are the continental United
States visiting all of the state
capitals passing through each state only
once what route should I take to
minimize the total distance the
following diagram shows the shortest
distances between neighboring Capital
Cities so like between capital of
Missouri and capital of Kentucky is 562
miles okay so so so you have the data
here on this on this graph and um you
can make a zdd uh uh you're supposed to
find a hamiltonian path of the smallest
total length in this in this graph so
what happens well
um it turns out that um there's a zdd of
7800 nodes uh for all the all the paths
um
uh from California to Maine that don't
that that don't go through any state
twice um and
um and uh not necessarily hamiltonian
but uh but these are simple paths just a
simple path it means that doesn't
doesn't hit any vertex twice uh and uh
you can also determine how many paths
there are of each length from California
to Maine and and you know there's four
Paths of length 11 124 of length 12 and
so on uh the longest paths are
hamiltonian and and there are two
million of them now um if we're just
okay anyway
um we can solve we can solve Randy's
problem and the to the total um running
time and I forget how many mega man
it's uh let's see so main to any other
state there's 68 Million Ways To Do It
um but exercise 230 contains the answer
so I show you the
answer and um I guess we better wind up
here
but
but these are the unique minimum and
maximum Roots um in his problem starting
from Maine
and they by by chance they both end up
in Virginia if you if if you if you
follow them through uh the best way is
11,000 some miles the worst way is
18,000 and some miles and um the amazing
thing is that with the zdd
um uh not you can not only easily figure
the um the shortest route and the
maximum route but you can also find the
average the cost of the average route
which is 14,000 some and the standard
deviation uh okay so between all these
roots all right so um and um somewhere
in here I I I mentioned the running time
which was quite which was quite
reasonable to to uh to do
this okay well
um there's
more uh as I I'm trying to find examples
of u i i i was I was looking at spanning
trees of a graph and and I had I had
constructed the the bdd for the
connected sets of a graph and that
appeared
um that appeared here I had to in this
in this graph I I wanted to say which
sets of edges are connected and this is
a Boolean function that's true if
they're connected and and false if they
aren't then um I I wanted
the but then I wanted the being
connected means it contains a spanning
tree so then I wanted the U I I I wanted
to the the bdd for all the um um all the
spanning trees uh in other words f ofx
is is one if and only if x is a spanning
tree of this graph and that's a lot
bigger um so I so I looked for the zdd
for for the spanning trees and um to my
surprise the zdd was exactly
this um and um so I said well that's you
know I better find another example
because uh but but uh I couldn't uh it
turned out that uh you take any any
connected graph and you form the bdd for
its connected subset that's also the zdd
for all the spanning
trees um and
um and and I I
uh I I I saw a shot in I I guess he had
to leave now uh he proved the converse
uh and conject the Converse that is if
if you have any any U uh graph of a
monotone function that's bdd is equal to
the zdd of its prime implicants uh if
and only if the prime implicants are the
um the independent sets of a matroid
which which is a anyway there there's
marvelous theorems out there just
waiting to be discovered uh these this
theorem is about a month old and um um
in in Paris last week I I met Jean Vima
who had been playing around with with
zdds to represent integers uh huge
integers and and doing operations like
multiplying integers represented as
zdds and uh um I believe then that
there's a u uh uh lot more uh coming in
this world as as more and more people
get to get to understand this uh
marvelous data structure okay excuse me
for for for for going so far over time I
just couldn't help it
oh